[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is a very
very special episode for those of you
who have been listening to the show for
a long time are no stranger to the name
Dr Gary Penn I always say whose book is
available now he's come up since the
beginning I mean if if you listen to the
show in the early years uh you saw in
real time how his guidance and his
wisdom shaped and changed my life and
you're about to listen to a Real Love
Fest that is filled with gems and
guidance and wisdom like I said from him
and just stories about our time together
and how I don't see him uh
professionally anymore first of all
let's get that out of the way the idea
that you go to therapy and they're like
oh that's how they get you you're going
to be in therapy the rest of your life I
haven't seen Gary Penn we realized in
nine years so he he he like installed
his software in my brain helped me and
now we got back together to talk to one
another and it was so wonderful this
this beautiful friendship homecoming so
get ready for a real a Real Love Fest
and a lot of just beautiful deep wisdom
from this wonderful man who does have a
book that is available now and it's
called I can't believe my life has come
to this and you're also going to enjoy I
hope I hope you're gonna I loved it I
hope you love it this is an incredible
chat I'm so happy that it finally
happened Dr Gary Penn is on the show
today and I don't have anything to plug
up top isn't that great just my tour
uh thanks to everybody who came to Largo
last night uh go to petehomes.com for
tickets to shows lots of new cities
coming up I'm really happy about this
new hour uh excited to be filming it in
Minneapolis this weekend this coming
weekend but all the tour dates now and
forever will always be on petehomes.com
hope you can see me
on the road and in the meantime enjoy
this incredible chat with my dear friend
and one of my great teachers and mentors
Dr Gary Ben I'm so excited get
into it it's so nice to see you Keith
is this okay is this professionally okay
it is
such a treat it's a treat I've been
looking forward to this since we booked
it yeah because people might not know
your Dr Gary Penn and you changed my
life I mean it's absolutely true I saw
you I came to you at such an important
time I don't know what you I'd love to
hear what you I don't want to talk the
whole time because I'm used to doing
that when I see you
but this is the intro yes this is the
context
that people need
I was um in a very talk I don't know if
you remember this I was in a like a
toxic relationship
um not that person's fault I'm not just
saying that to be kind we just weren't a
good match a lot of things were right
but a lot of things just weren't and I
don't remember who
told me about you
but it was such a stroke of Grace
because I had seen a therapist before
and they were sort of more of the um
and I love this as well but they were
more they just they just listened and
you're more of uh you're like my stats
my Stutz like the Jonah Hill yeah yeah
yeah you would give me advice
and and you got me out of this mire
and again I really don't want to be
unkind to that person but it was just
the wrong situation for both of us and
if I had stayed in it I don't think I
was like
285. I I was drinking constantly like
day drinking she was a smoker so I would
smoke sick I blame her but I would smoke
cigarettes because I'm just with a
smoker I swear to God I felt embarrassed
that she was smoking and I wasn't it was
like deeply codependent well you've
already like rescued the person it
wasn't their fault like you're you're a
caregiver I'm trying yes you know yeah
yeah this guy hit my car but God my
history
in his defense I was in the way yes yeah
well you got you got the really I have
to be somewhat public you got me just
being like this person inside or
whatever it was yeah and that was such a
gift
this is a long way to say
you installed a Dr Gary pen in my brain
in my in my Consciousness that I then
went to and this is the thing I always
tell about you too is I saw you for
years and then I stopped seeing you now
we're really in a good intro and now I'm
seeing you for the first time in years
here how how many years Pete I couldn't
tell you
yeah yeah I I want you to know I think
you should hold it closer like an ice
cream I want you to know yeah there you
go that I have a Hall of Fame in my
office oh this is very good for me of
what if you're like and you're not it
you just mentioned that no no this isn't
about you actually okay good about the
people that you've of you've from your
people people love you yes I mean people
just adore you and they they come to see
you now so many people at your
recommendation yes and it's like how did
you hear about me Pete Holmes how did
you hear about me Pete Holmes Pete
Holmes and what's fascinating because
other people give me you know
recommendations but they're all like
cool people yeah they're smart they're
interesting people all the patients that
come in yeah and it's like they love you
oh well that's wonderful I mean they
just think you're like
well they are like you know you you have
this sense about you that first any
anyone asked me about you first thing
out of my mouth he's wicked smart oh
that's now you made me believe that
actually I think when I started seeing
you I didn't know I was smart I I know
that's crazy it's kind of crazy but you
need like therapy and you specifically
like an older male figure it's like
Mythic you need like an ob1 you do yeah
that goes like hey you're smart and like
and week after week it like starts to
sink in so thank you for saying that
yeah it's kind of like me saying you're
tall and you go well wait a minute
really well this is great because it's
stuck the the me that didn't know he was
smart isn't there anymore that's right
he lovingly he didn't leave he merged he
grew up he grew up into something better
in one of my analysis uh in my last
analysis
I I I had a um a reunion in my high
school reunion and one of the things I
said to him is
and I'm not a tall man I'm about I was
five eleven now you know I'm getting
close to 70. so I'm getting on the other
side of that wow but I but I did
um but I did say to my analysts it was
interesting I was taught I'm a taller
than a lot of the my friends yeah in
high school yeah I just felt small yes
yeah and it was so so interesting like I
thought that I was shorter than them
well oh speaking of Mythic there is a
myth it's the it's the myth of the the
wolf that's raised by sheep do you know
that one tell me it's real it's real
brief it's right up your alley but there
so a wolf separated by it from his
wolves and and finds a bunch of sheep
and he starts hanging out with the sheep
and they give him wool and they cover
him up and he eats the grass and he he's
raised by them until he's you know a
young man wolf like you know middle-aged
wolf then a wolf sees this ridiculous
Society sees a wolf covered in balls of
wool hanging out with sheep and he's
like what are you doing and he takes
this oh it'll make me cry he takes the
wolf and he finds a puddle and he and he
puts his face over and goes you're a
wolf like look at yourself you're a wolf
and I like this party then he gives a
meat I guess you could say he kills on
the sheep but the way I heard it he just
gives him meat and the and the young
wolf chokes on the meat which I think is
essential because there's always that
resistance every every movie Once you
know this formula every movie has the
Call to Adventure and then you resist
the call you don't want to go yes Luke
doesn't want to go yes then his aunt and
uncle are killed yeah and then he has to
go there you go by the way watch any
movie and this is there it's it's
classic Joseph Campbell so he chokes on
the meat that's the small version of the
resisting like you're a wolf but then he
realizes I'm a wolf and somebody like
brings him home but you need that that
archetype it's powerful I it's it's one
of the reasons why in my work I can't
tell you how often I quote Star Wars
yeah because it's so it's such
low-hanging fruit yeah I mean what you
just talked about is really quite
beautiful right and and in Star Wars
it's the same thing it's this it's this
archetypal idea of being a man I think a
lot of the problems we're having in our
world right now is because men are just
completely lost yeah and they've lost
their masculinity they don't know how to
be yeah and when you were talking about
the wolf I was thinking like how would
this go in Florida the wolf this is like
conversion therapy or something yeah
oh my God you're telling me to be
something that I'm not yeah yeah it
could be scary but it is you know you're
reminding me of something else I heard
it's another it's not a myth it was a
Mythic Storyteller I heard him talk
about how so many young men are suicidal
and he framed it really beautifully he
was like what they realize is don't
don't jump off the bridge he's not
trying to be funny he he realized he
goes there is a part of you that needs
to die yes and that gets confused do I
need to die exactly right doesn't that
just give you the chills it does it's so
smart a lot of times when I'm working
with couples go over the bridge sorry
that was the end of it he goes go over
the bridge don't you don't jump over the
bridge but when you get to the other
side you left something behind yes sorry
when I work with couples
um often
the marriage is so shitty and I tell
them this marriage has to die
like this marriage is over yeah like
whether we can reconstruct another
marriage we can another relationship
that's healthy but the one that you're
living right now is rotted to the core
yeah yeah so it's the same kind of thing
like you don't have to die you just have
to sit there and say look at exactly
what's in front of you yeah take off the
Vaseline and say this isn't pretty and
answer the call yeah so when I saw you
and I was in that relationship that I
keep trying to you know white glove it
but like I was really miserable nobody
who
for me I was 50 pounds heavier like 40
45 pounds heavier than I am now so that
I'm already I'm pretty big now I was so
it's pretty big drinking constantly
smoking constantly because uh somebody
called it a cocktail relationship they
were like it makes sense three cocktails
in like you're like this is fun if
you're a little so true isn't that good
so true it's like this works this works
so that was my coping you know that was
like a stress in my life if I if I
sobered up and I was like I don't know
about this I have a [__] now I have a
cocktail it's like another kind of meat
how have a meat you're this you're this
you're this yes and one of the things
that you said to me was
and it
again it's just making me so grateful
for you how far I've come is I told you
I was making a list of reasons to break
up with this person because I thought
breaking up with a person everybody that
listens to the show or has listened to
the show knows I feel this way I thought
it was like a mean thing to do yes it's
like an unkind yes so I was making a
list the list by the way
was very long
and you said this is this is come on not
not your wolf like you're mean but like
come on you can say yes to a different
situation like like you're saying to
those troubled marriages like you guys
can kill this and say yes to something
better and we'll start it today yes
together but you said
um and I remember it vividly because you
probably had to say it more than once
you were like you don't need a list you
can just say
um I don't I don't need to give you a
reason which was absurd right I don't
have to build a case right because this
person I had tried to break up with them
nine times it's stuck on the tenth time
but nine times I'd broken up with him
and they talked me out of it it was just
it's that scene in Glenn Gary Glenn Ross
where Al Pacino's talking to James Link
and he's just like I can't negotiate
this like you're just better than me and
I'm gonna buy this yeah so please stop
talking that's funny that's how I felt
that's a great example right she was
just better at sales yeah and I was like
I'm unarmed for this and you were like
you don't need them to say it's okay you
could and this was the quote you go I'm
gonna bounce that's all you said and
sorry all these memories are coming back
she also used to yell at me and I was so
scared I didn't know this terminology
but I would go into my child self yeah I
would become seven years old yeah I'm
huge we've already covered this yes and
I thought she could flick me like an ant
into a volcano I thought she could kill
me yeah and you said when that happens
after it's reached a point where like
you weren't teaching me avoidance but
you're like if she's just being unfair
to you as Eckhart totally would say
she's just in her pain body she's just
looking for something to feed on you
would say you you said oh God I love you
for this you went you have a credit card
that's right and I was like yeah I have
a credit card and you're like any hotels
any hotels near where you live yes and
I'm like the thought of it now look at
this yeah I'm now a person that would do
that I would go this is talk we lived in
the same building so I was like this
this isn't working I'm gonna leave and I
don't even have to yes I don't owe you
and I don't have to delete it it's a
revelation yeah people will come to my
office and someone say my husband's this
and he's this and I said and I said how
did you get here
and they go I drove I go well you have a
car and they go yes
I go real and you have credit cards you
go yes yeah I said oh that's that's
remarkable but the Spells were under
right spells were under and the Spells
we agreed to be placed under it's it's
about it's about we get in trouble when
those parts of us get split off
the powerful Parts the the no the the
the
dysfunctional or the or the boy yeah the
boy gets split off
and the boy that was you
seven years old yeah yeah mine mine was
six years old yeah I I he's still alive
yeah at this point if if I'm walking
down the street with you
and we come upon a homeless person to
this day
because you're with me there's maybe a
seven percent chance that I'm going to
give this person money more than enough
hour by myself yeah
six-year-old Gary
and he wants to say hey Petey look at me
yeah aren't I a good boy good boy yeah
I'm a good boy he still exists buddy
okay so I was just talking to somebody
about this and they were very top down
and Val is very bottom up so she's
always trying to get me to be in my body
and learn about that boy right and again
I I feel emotional just talking about
him but we I was trying to explain to
this I'm very top down too but he was
very heady and I was trying to be like
there are irrational responses there
just are you go like well that's stupid
I'm not seven but it's just happening so
the example that came to mind was my
parents are always trying to get me to
visit more often it's classic yeah
um I my parents to say something
positive about them they're very good at
jokes they'll take dark jokes I'll be
like uh yeah none of us really enjoy
that and they'll like laugh it's like my
favorite thing about them you definitely
taught me that too is is just I feel so
good about myself yeah Don't Spray air
freshener on the elephant turd yeah
because it's teaching us something like
I'm a piece of [__] yeah so pay
attention yeah and if we keep on
spraying we're going to step in it and
then we're going to get it all over us
you pay attention to the [__] pay
attention but my dad you know he said
look my parents aren't going to speak
the way that I want them to speak that's
fine they're doing better than their
parents I'm not just trying to be sweet
they're doing better than their parents
and I'm doing better with language than
they are but um and that's just how life
is but my dad was like all he said was
been a while and I wanted to be like
guilt is not sexy
you know what I mean yes that's your
voice in me I go like we got to do
better than girls how about I miss you
there you go how about
you know what's coming
your interest and I'd like to go and
watch you enjoy that or I I I when
you're at dinner everybody well that is
what they would say everybody's happier
and that's just that's just the Savior
thing come and rescue us but the thing
is so I will say no you know I'll go
like you know we just saw you we saw you
this and we'll figure it out very Cat's
in the Cradle I'll just be like we'll
figure out when's a good time I'm really
just kind of not going as directly as
you why
why not say Dad that's guilt
um Dad I don't really like it whatever
it is it's because of the seven-year-old
and I've tried to find that balance and
I'd love to hear your thoughts on it
I could go well it's [__] and we
hate it and we don't want to visit but
there's part of me that goes like that's
going to be rough on the boy and I'm
instead gonna play it a little safer
because I don't want him to wrestle with
that confrontation but but there's the
other part Pete is
you love your father and you love your
mother and and they're good people like
they're they're not monsters no right
they're they're good people
so there's a part of you that wants to
say you know Pop I love you and I know
you want me to come yeah but I'm not
going to
so
so you say you know you tell him so he
doesn't have to repeat it 18 times you
go I know that you really want us to
come and I know you miss us desperately
but we're not going to come right now
but we love you and we're going to come
probably in a couple months and we'll be
here and yeah so the that part of you
that name it is yeah and I think that
part of you that says that is not the
boy it's taking care of your father
yeah it's kind of like a very
compassionate adult thing for you to do
the part of you that might get a little
bit like this with the heart yeah and
that might be the boy like am I in
trouble or is he gonna do that well
that's what I was getting at too is like
I think what's crazy about the little
boy it sounds so cute oh there's a
little boy in me and he's scared he
actually thinks that if you don't mind
if you don't resolve the conflict you're
going to die like I really think that's
why he does that's why that person
within us little boy little girl
why they have such a seat at the table
because they come to our world in a
they go hello who is it
it's a it's seven-year-old Pete it's
six-year-old Gary I got something to
tell you really why do you have to come
and sit down I'm going to make you some
hors d'oeuvres you want a cocktail
something to drink what are you telling
me well if you do this you're going to
be rejected you're going to be alone the
rest of your life no one's ever going to
love you we think that they are give
they are the word of God right they are
Moses at the burning bush yeah thou will
be alone for the rest of like Jesus
Christ yeah yeah so that's why we listen
and so what we do a lot of times is we
say why am I being so stupid
what's wrong with me which only
validates that that Young Person's voice
it only validates his hideousness which
actually makes him stronger in the
negative
yeah does that make sense yeah yeah so
instead of doing that what I've what
I've thought I think is a really great
response instead of saying why do I do
that because whenever anyone gives me
like a why like what why are you wearing
this shirt Gary it's always a bad
question because I have bad taste like
there's never a good answer for that
right so instead of saying why
try this how interesting that I do this
yeah how interesting that I feel just
notice that because then we have a sense
of hmm let me explore it yeah little
Gary wouldn't say how interesting would
do it but so that's why it's so powerful
these voices within us getting curious
about it getting curious about it and I
you know there's a picture of around us
he talks about our our errant thoughts
and they bother us that brings back a
memory because you tell me you would
mention romnn not thus all the time I
did oh yeah I was just finding him yeah
yeah it was good but he talked about
you're meditating and like a thought
won't stop and he goes like don't resist
it you sort of tussle its hair like a
little child and just send it on its way
yeah so it's it's the energy that we
give these things in the resistance yes
right it's like it's true energy and a
lot of times we think that we're trying
to advance ourselves by hating ourselves
like oh God what's wrong with Mika why
can't I talk to that that girl over
there so what what someone said it
instead of like I know I can't talk to
her yeah I know that I didn't have any
masculine presence in my life or my mom
was always screaming I know why yeah so
you say the only option for me is not to
be James Bond but to walk over to her
and say you know listen I get really
nervous talking to pretty women yeah but
I wanted to say hello to you you must
have taught that to me because when I
was single I if I was in a bar the most
honest thing I could say if I it would
always be me and [__] Joe to Rosa
and would just be standing there having
drinks and I'm like this isn't why we
came here we came here to hopefully talk
to to women yeah that's why that's what
bars are yes I mean not always but
that's what this bar was for sure in
this neighborhood but we were just kind
of standing around and I would just
get honest like you were saying and I
would go up to a group of girls that
were probably also there for the same
reason I don't you can't know I'm not
assuming but I would go up and say Vegas
odd say yes yes exactly the bar I'm
thinking of it it's it's a real dive but
we would just go up and I would say the
truth which is
I I came here with my friend I talked to
him all the time and I'm so bored great
and those led to like I'm not just
talking about sealing the deal and
having sex I mean they they led to like
great nights like great memories these
two groups merged everyone won that's
right and that didn't happen a lot
meaning I wasn't always in my highest
self that I could be brave and do that
but I remember vividly the line was
I'm bored talking to my friends what are
you guys talking about yeah and you can
tell like I'll go away but I just I'm
bored are you bored yeah
are you bored and I think that's pretty
compelling that's not bad the honesty is
compelling right I might steal that in
my work I'm sorry it's your anniversary
no for your work I thought you were
gonna go to a bar
your wife's right there
we're gonna edit that one out
oh we got it that's the clip that's the
internet I'm just kidding no you can you
can absolutely use that but that's your
voice that's what I mean is is naming
things you're always trying to get me to
be a little bit more
honest and a little bit more yes and
what do you find when you're honest like
I this is going back to our beginning of
our conversation but
it's one of the things I like to tell
people all the time is just because
we're not being nice doesn't mean we're
being mean right and yes and it's like I
I tell them like we'll I'll be in
session and someone was saying well I
don't want to you know I don't want to
hurt my my father's you know feelings
and I said I I don't want to be mean I
go let me show you what mean looks like
you know Dad you [__] you're just
like you just won't leave me the [__]
alone I don't know what's wrong with you
you just keep on your you want more you
want more you want more like that's mean
yeah yeah let me show you what's not
mean you know Pop I love you I love Mom
I'd love to see you we're going to but
we're not going to make it right now so
I mean as you say that there's something
inside me starts to cry literally it's
that simple because you're catching me
realizing that what I'm saying is
unspeakably cruel right that I'm just
like you know I I literally
we'll hang up the fun and it'll stay
with me then just like yeah what have I
done and let me show you and just just
be a screenwriter what does mean look
like yeah yeah I know I know are you
kidding me right I'd rather drink Rants
and milk you know come over to your
house yeah yeah that's mean yeah and
when I say that people go well I'm not
that's not mean at all I'm saying you
know I won't be able to make it until
you know June or July right come you
it's just I feel like I'm gonna have to
pay my co-pay at this
but that's what I was hoping I was
hoping that that we could turn people on
to the voice that you've you've put in
that I still that I still have and and
you you talked about you did help me you
ushered me into a type of manhood that I
wasn't comfortable with and and Val
uh if she were my wife obviously
is like the beneficiary of someone who's
made a certain degree of peace with that
um like what this isn't exactly the
right example but like maybe we'll get
back to that but like the if whenever I
do my impression of you it's always who
cares
that was always what you said who cares
because I'd come in and I would tell you
some well the everybody knows the
example I was in an apartment it had
very thin walls I'm not I've told it I'm
a little embarrassed your wife is here
but like very thin walls and my
neighbors had were having loud sex and
it turned me on and I it wasn't my wife
it was your wife having sex yeah and I
knew that and that's what really got me
going that would be really weird no it
would but so it's a little naughty right
yeah I masturbated because even as I
said I I'm not flesh I'm not flesh I'm
not I feel like I maybe ought to be but
I'm not because I've told the story many
times
and I told you that but one the boy the
guy the boy that told you that
felt like such a skis and so dirty and
broken
and like I had violated like the idea of
them
you know what I mean you're writing the
script yeah exactly yes I had betrayed a
social contract you're you're supposed
to pretend put on the radio and pretend
you don't hear it I don't know what
you're supposed to do noise canceling
earphones I don't know I was horny I
heard sex and I masturbated yeah and you
went who cares
it's very erotic that's what you said
and we say we say on the show all it's
like a catchphrase it's very erotic
which was the most masterful way of just
being like it's literally
evolutionarily the reason why women have
loud orgasms is to arouse men yes
accordingly it's such a miracle
to to get an erection
I mean it is a miracle however we get
there right well it's like however you
want it I mean the example that I like
to use is from Castaway look what I did
I made fire yeah look what I've created
and it's like this is why we're so proud
of our wieners yeah if you even if you
have a small one you know that this
little wiener could become this little
little less you know little and it could
make life that's something yeah it's
like we're so proud of our wieners and
it's so yeah but it also makes us the
weaker sex because God forbid we can't
get it up yes which is why I think women
are much stronger than we are because
holy Christ if we can't figure it out
I've had I have so many jokes about this
you do I say like I think the worst
thing about being a gay man must be like
if you lose your erection because losing
your erection with a woman is bad but
losing your erection with someone who
has an erection
is like the worst not it's like oh it's
so easy for you like and you're just
there like I'm so sorry it's like the
before and after yeah right but I also
had a bit see Val's helped me with this
too I I was always I had this bit on
stage where I was like men achieve an
erection like you want to put yes you
want to put a metal all around it like
an Olympic medal this is why we need to
build things this is why that's what the
Olympic torch is by the way yeah that's
right yeah and you know women have that
drive too but not not the same as us
like we have to create something we have
to build something we have to grow
something yeah yeah right that's right
pouch envy and and Donald Trump's name
on buildings and big skyscrapers and all
that sort of stuff it's making up for
the fact that yeah we're just we're
we're not the dandelion we're the wish
flowers that we just blow the seat
around right right isn't that funny one
of the most feminine images is like a
child is going that's us that's us
that's right we're just anybody and
we'll go to Great Lanes anybody want
this yeah we'll do that right yeah yeah
yeah but we don't that's that's really
interesting so tell more memories are
going to come to me don't tell me about
who cares how much of how much of your
job is saying who cares
to yourself is that a coping thing not a
coping is
I think my what my my brand is I
I'm very plain spoken
yeah I'm just very pronounced I gotta
for all the
people that are going to listen to this
or watch this this podcast
my my Powers as Pete is telling you how
great my powers are I I tell Pete
to go climb Mount Everest and you climb
it
and I'm I'm the Miracle Man because I
say hey go climb Everest like it's it's
such a joy when you work with someone
and you say and you take the football
and you go down and you score it's like
unbelievable by coaching a game yeah
yeah it's like unbelievable so there's a
part that is like this is why you're
like I can't say you're my favorite
patient
you're my favorite
oh good I'm glad we had that on three
cameras
I just can't say it oh that's wonderful
but but because it must be frustrating
if people yeah yeah and so you use
metaphors you use whatever you can to
get people to to do these things but the
fact that I could say it to you and you
you were just so receptive yeah and then
you in your brain could would
automatically just make
you would make sense of it all yeah and
then you would say that's right it was
almost like it's very Socratic like
almost like you had the answers all
along and I was just like well why do I
laugh when you talk it's it's like when
when you hear the truth yeah it's really
funny
like saying this isn't working I'm going
to bounce so I can use the word bounds
which I thought was really fun yeah
because it kept it light that's right
it's not even I'm going to leave I'm
gonna bounce that's right it's funny I'm
gonna go yeah I'm gonna leave so lightly
I'm actually bouncing I'm gonna bounce
this right here like because I don't
want to be abused anymore I'm gonna
bounce that's right because it
detoxifies it all yeah it makes it like
we think like I'm gonna really hurt your
feelings
if I say you know Pete I gotta go man I
gotta bounce like I'm saying uh God
you're such a horrible how like we we
come up with these stories yeah
especially like if we've had an
upbringing where whatever we say is I'm
causing my mother to drink or my father
to get depressed or why isn't my father
being a father to me all right right
every child would say it's their fault
right right the way we have we're
perfectly omnipotent when we're Childs
yeah yeah you know if you I work with
people who've been adopted from the
vajayjay to the new family and they will
to the 50 years later they'll say why
was why was that night good enough right
to keep right
I think that's very interesting I think
that's just a fundamental human wound it
is let's not get ahead of ourselves but
I actually think that might almost be an
echo of a Divine existential like we've
we've broken away from God like like the
Garden of Eden sort of thing
could you could you elaborate on that
only if you really want me to I do that
sounds really interesting yeah I think
one of the things that might be going on
here is that God is one everything is
one in reality it's all one and then we
what are we doing here we split so I
think we walk around with a low level of
confusion at best but maybe even guilt
and fear at worst which is like we've
broken away we've broken away from from
God's perfect Oneness God yes so if God
is one which most of the religions of
their deeper mystical levels would agree
it's all one it's a non-dual framework
yes what the [__] is happening then
because I'm over here and you're over
there yes oh then some a voice the ego
which is a liar
says you killed God God's mad you've
broken away then we make this world
where we can kill each other so you're
guilty and I'm not we scapegoat we
project and at least uh we can hide here
for a little while before he comes and
kills us now as I say that I think
that's deeply Freudian and it can you
can go less deep and just stop at the
mother and we split from that Oneness
and then we have this mother wound and
that guilt so there's also like you
could look at it expand it to like a
universal idea yes
the that's very good that's very
interesting it's interesting I'm going
to listen to this on the back end and
learn something more play that it
happens because my I'm bleeding a little
bit I didn't make it up it's from A
Course in Miracles and Helen chuckman
who wrote it was a psychologist she
scribed it yeah she was a psychologist
so it's very Freudian it is it is true
that if if when people talk about if we
want to go a little bit into religion if
people go like
um the idea of God or a deity if God is
everything right if God is everything
then there's nothing like is there a
hell
does Hell exist well if hell exists then
you're instantly defining minimizing God
because God is everything but hell right
if if God is my cup of tea not not my
cup of tea
then God is everything but not my
company you've drawn a border around us
yeah yeah so all of a sudden God is
limited right so you know what my you
brought back a vivid memory though
because I went to a Christian college
and I would say things like that and I
remember my friend Heath was like no God
is the ruler of hell not the devil and
he Delights in it and I was like this is
you know what that is though at least
it's honest that is you know what I mean
that is I was like thank you yeah if
it's gonna be in my opinion a sadistic
yeah God who didn't like that I
masturbated hearing my neighbors and
wants to torture me for eternity for
sins accrued during 80 90 years who
knows uh if that's really the plan of
this of this all-powerful yes incredible
being yes uh then at least make him do
it don't make a devil that does it but
you know what I'm saying yes yes because
then you're drawing a border around it
yeah on a border so that's yeah so
that's interesting though that's the
rocky can't lift yeah no I I was curious
about your um we usually get into it
later but you had that was your office
right because I remember seeing Eastern
philosophy and yeah some of that stuff
and it came up from time to time yes
meaning I think if you believed if you
Dr Gary Penn believed in a
punishing God it would have come out in
your yes you wouldn't have been like who
cares you would have been like well yeah
you should you should get a edible
arrangement for your neighbors sorry I
listened just write sorry I listened to
nothing else Bill no
they'll know
I uh but it informs your worldview as
well my world view is I have a um
I have like a 48 by 48 photograph from
the Hubble telescope right behind the
couch where my my clients sit
and it's a deep State it's a deep deep
space thing of all these galaxies and so
people are behind me and they're talking
about the mundacity of life
and I'm looking at
hundreds of galaxies that were and now
I'm going to get another one based on
the James Webb but yeah I love that so
much because it always centers me yeah
because when we're complaining about oh
my my masturbated and all these things
and I'm not you know advancing far
enough it always centers me and I have a
ton of books on astrophysics and physics
because it always makes it makes me
happy to know the enormity of
and then in our brains how we just
shrink it down to this little tumor and
we're sitting there thinking
it's so enticing we think we're working
the problem if we cannibalize ourselves
yeah
I'll Whip myself that's right and we're
being lazy if we say
I'm great yeah which is the your
okay the Course in Miracles would also
say if I can see you as a child of God
as perfect love that's how I see myself
like and if I go you're a piece of [__]
I know Gary's lost to these [__]
[__] weird and selfish like I'm weird
I'm selfish I'm broke and I'm you it's
all it's all the same it's it's all the
uh and the more you do it
it's about your own shadow it's the it's
it's a quintessential
Evangelical preacher railing against
homosexuality that's right and how much
you want to bet what he does in on his
internet he's having nine Affairs yeah
or sex workers and all that sort of it's
a cliche of course and I know I catch
myself doing that there's a picture of
my dad over there I catch myself the
things I complain about my dad I'm I
know I'm doing like that's why they're
so delicious to me but to go to your
Cosmos thing
when you I've I've had a lot of
psychedelic experiences where you were
it's not just a concept all one or God
is love or something you have like an
experiential yes timeless it feels like
the James it's as vast as that so I feel
like that is this have you ever had
those kinds of experiences oh yeah I
have yeah many many some of them sober
too I mean not on on a drug but like
that same experience you're having
look at this person's thinking about
like I told my dad I don't want to visit
and look at where he said it
it's a joke it's a comedy joke to go
like in this galaxy on this planet
that's right there was a little that's
right that's right and in his little
pockets he had a little wallet yeah and
there's a little ChapStick and someone's
keeping score on what you're doing well
the audacity and I actually
the thought that we think we can upset
God is I think a form of of narcissism
it's total narcissism you agree yeah oh
yeah it's yeah I said [__] and God wrote
it down is like you think God is like
the Jason Bourne control room yes yes
get the [__] over yourself I call it
malevolent omnipotence malevolent where
bad things happen because of me but good
things happen in spite of me it's like
some people they just go dark on
themselves right you got to be a real
douche to say everything that goes well
it's because of me like right those kind
of people you're going like dude like
really it's another type of
self-centeredness that's right is that
how
I guess I I would love to just find ways
to load you into your classic DG penis
is there a lot of narcissism what what
are people dealing with what is the
thing you know it's it's interesting
because my wife's here and she's an
amazing artist
and what I've been telling her
because she's the sweetest I'm not going
to get emotional it's she's the sweetest
most it is their anniversary
she's the sweetest most kindest you know
just and I was I've been can I tell you
how healing that is just that example
like you remain an archetype in me and
it pains when I talk about me loving my
mom and my dad I didn't mean to
interrupt I'm just saying that was
beautiful and it's so valuable I'm so
glad you said it because people that
love their Partners yes
and especially for a while I mean what
anniversary is this yeah what 13 13 yeah
we started late yeah still I mean
[__] beautiful beautiful and it's
just like
it's just um I wanted to say that we had
sex the other night but my my wife gets
mad no I know because whenever we have
whenever we have sex I tell everybody
I swear to God it's the weirdest thing I
was playing golf on Sunday we had sex on
Saturday and I was telling everyone I've
had sex last first thing out of my mouth
in someone's backswing I hope I had sex
last night into the woods
and what do you think that is
anyway
go on wait a doctor
I find that significantly showing my mom
I got a little poop here like look what
I did that's right that's right okay so
I said you know I said honey you need
a big shot of narcissism
and this toxic narcissism but then
there's really good narcissism right and
a lot of people they're just so afraid
to say I'm I'm great at what I do yeah
I'm really good and what I have to offer
is wonderful and it's beautiful yes and
it's like we're so afraid like what will
people think if like
what is that about like what is that
about where you just can't say I I'm
I'm great I have a theory yes because
the the more success I've had you do
start to feel a little isolated I was
talking about this is a weird thing to
say but things go sideways and you're up
there's no GoFundMe you know what I'm
saying you don't you don't you can't go
to your friends and go right I can't pay
the landscapers yes so there is like
this weird
isolation and I think we're I'm reading
this book called The War of art have you
have you read the war of art you would
like it it's very much like you I can
summarize it in uh three words it's just
do it just write it but then he breaks
down what you're afraid of and one of
them is if I succeed I'll be an outlier
and I'll be alone so it's it's like the
seven-year-old boy if I if I humiliate
My Father by outshining him he will eat
me it is you know it's it's well this is
a little tangential but when we
um
when we evolve and we we grow
um we become lonely yeah because it's
like the bell curve the further you go
along
the fewer people it's easier to be in I
mean it's the bottom end of the bell
curve you're down here alone yeah it's
it's like
it's like it's like
it's easy to be at the big um San
Antonio Convention Center
hands raised that were being saved by by
Jesus or whoever and you're feeling like
and it's harder to go do the hard work
of
like what you're doing and you say when
you're reading and you're exploring and
you understand you're and you're
challenging yourself to understand yeah
it's a Road Less Traveled right
sometimes it's very lonely so there can
be a fear to that it's good fear to that
it's a fear to that when you break up
with somebody and you do something for
help that's what she said by the way she
said when it when it finally stuck she
was like you'll see you think great
people like me are everywhere you'll see
what is she saying subtitles on she's
saying you're making a mistake you're
going to be alone you're going to be
alone you can't do better than me oh
interesting you know what I mean that's
what I took it as like interesting and
who said that again the girl that the
woman that I broke up after all time
together but that's and you know what
else happened sorry I want to get back
to helpful narcissism so I have a pin in
that but when we broke up
um the first thought I had was what if
there's an earthquake and I realized I
had been ascribing to her a role like
almost like a maternal or a paternal a
parenting role like you make me safe
that's right your fear and your
scariness and your sexuality all of it
yes makes me safe and I'll I and
finalize myself
one time we had a fight I I just think
this is helpful we had a fight which
means she just yelled at me that doesn't
mean I kind of wish I had fought to be
honest but I just was berated and scared
and I got in the car and I I sat there
with the in the driveway for like five
minutes trying to remember where
Franklin was and we lived between
Hollywood and Franklin you could see
Franklin but I was so Frozen so in my in
my fight flight freeze and I was frozen
I couldn't think it's right there it's
it's Le it's one of two choices so these
these fear things take us over so the
narcissist The Helpful narcissism was
helpful in that breakup and and you're
saying it applies to creative Endeavors
I think totally it does because because
what was let's say preventing
my wife from getting critical mass
was not feeling the power not not
feeling yeah you know not not feeling
this sense of power and
and and and
excitement and and knowing that this is
going to be great it's it there's a this
is going to be great or I hope it's
great or I hope it's not bad yeah
if I'm sitting over if I'm the Masters
and I'm uh the Masters Golf Tournament
and I got a 20-foot putt
the sports psychologists will say we
want you to visualize the ball going in
the hall yeah right it's like okay it's
20 feet it's 20 feet it's a little right
to left little downhill make a good
stroke instead of I hope I don't [__] it
up I hope I don't make a mistake I hope
I don't do this yeah and you're gonna
grip too too tightly yes and you're
going to miss the so it's that kind of
narcissism I'm going to yes like Michael
Jordan yes you know Tiger Woods they
visualize it going in the home they
understood the this is what I always
make this joke I want this is why
advertising works it's like what we hear
changes your behavior changes your
reality and and they've told us that
Twizzlers make a movie better and we go
I think Twizzlers makes it how many
people ate Italian food when they
watched The Sopranos we mirror these
things and you're mirroring yes these
unhealthy repetitive patterns in your
mind is that that seems to be what's
happening in the dark side of our
country yeah sure people are mirroring
Trump yes right and he's giving us a an
externalization of some of our more base
yes Trump is my dad can beat up your dad
writ large and he's the dad that you say
he can beat you up and I actually it was
a exercise and compassion to go like I
get it you know what I mean I get the
guy that goes like
shut up everything's like ozone layer
there's no ozone layer it's fine and I
was like there's a real comfort in that
I'll give you an example from my own
life my dad he wasn't a coveted denier
but he wasn't being careful he actually
brought it home and gave it to my mom
and in Darker moments I'm like what if
that had gone the other way she was an
at-risk person but she's kind of worked
out which is annoying in its own way but
also I'm glad that it worked out yes and
I really got curious like you about that
I was like
my dad didn't wear a mask and and he
kind of was like
and I found I'm not saying all of me
because my intellect and my grown person
was like that's irresponsible to sex and
then I found the part of me that was
like yeah he's my dad he's Invincible I
found the my dad can beat up kovid part
of me and it helped me
find compassion sometimes you're so
scared you'd rather have a guy that goes
like coverage moving like that's that's
the best you can do
that's really interesting I think that
makes a lot of sense that is like
that's one of the smartest things that
I've heard is like I've always been like
a little puzzle like
why are these people like voting against
their interests and like what's the
matter with Kansas like what the [__]
why are these people doing this yeah and
it's like oh I feel safe yeah yeah he's
I mean I I could I can understand
getting behind him yeah and being like
yeah this guy this guy's crazy you know
what I mean like this guy's [__] nuts
and he's a president and I'm crazy too
so I could be like you know right it's
what we're talking about it's like
projecting and scapegoating and stuff I
think a lot of liberals uh will go I
can't relate to that at all and I'm like
I think you need to go take the elevator
low or maybe or not even lower let's
just say to a different floor and find a
a weirder part because watching the show
succession did you watch succession I
watched some of it I didn't watch all of
it this is a weird thing to say but my
Logan Roy the dad character reminds me
of my dad in some ways and and how so
easy
I'll stick the landing on the point and
we can Circle back to that but he
anytime the kids because they're all
trying to usurp him anytime the kids do
and he's a little bit broken
I can't handle it and it made me
recognize I thought I just wanted to
defeat my father or break him and then
it helped me get in touch with a truer
part of me which was like
what you pointed out already I I think
the people I'm protective of my parents
are at the top like I wouldn't want to
the thought of my dad being broken and
going like you know I am scared of covid
and the end of life is overwhelming to
me like I couldn't handle it oh no no no
no Red Sox Red Sox here's a here's some
ice cream let's watch the game big fella
like I can't handle it like I thought I
wanted to to defeat him I figured out
it's way more tender than them
it's a little heartbreaking your
father's 70s and 80s I just turned 80.
yeah he it's it's it's such a shame that
they just that people
just can't be like fluent in how they
think about these things like how they
think about death and talking about it
and it's like how they just like we
can't talk my family was so locked down
so so incredibly locked down
um
my parents would not with five kids in
my family
they would not tell the kids how old
they were
let's pick a moment of silence here
please wow they wouldn't tell like a
denial I got a birthday we don't know
how old they were wow like they would
not tell us how old they were
wow and it's like how old are you now
now we don't do that it's like finally
when you know when they were
my mom had like her purse or something
and we we got to the driver's license ah
we felt like we won the lottery oh she's
you know 47 like we yeah we finally knew
but so locked down that's just a
metaphor for everything for sex for this
for that for money like death how they
feel and I tell people all the time talk
to your children about death yeah how
you think about it how you feel about it
what you want them to think about when
you go and just be very conversant about
it right let's not make it a boogie man
like oh my god well I you know you're
bringing up a I just called my mom this
weekend and she unfortunately she has
Parkinson's she's doing fine but she
just got diagnosed sorry to hear that
yeah me too but then I think she watched
the Michael J fox documentary and she
was like that stupid Michael J Fox like
she was like against him she was like
that nincompoop Michael J fox and I was
like what this guy made a movie about
your disease you'd think she would be
like you would think thank you for your
honesty or your vulnerability what she
didn't like about it was that she was
like he talked about falling why don't
you have a walker he talked about
um he could barely talk shouldn't the
medicine be helping him and I was like
Mom he's look I was like tell me if this
isn't a therapist move I go I hear a lot
of fear of course I go I hear a lot of
fear and I understand
and then I was I was just kind of poking
around what kind of conversation are we
going to have I said and also wasn't it
kind of vulnerable that he was honest
yeah and I was and and she's the one who
gave me
or introduce me to Faith and it's so
funny that like as she's getting older
she's kind of going
more you know like more on her own which
is a weird move to me but anyway but I
go
mom we can't put our faith in our bodies
like that that's that's silly and this
is like an AAA thing I go the
Parkinson's isn't the problem the fear
is the problem like let's talk about the
fear the Parkinson's isn't doing
anything in this moment you're afraid In
This Moment none of this was was working
it was just that nincompoop like that's
so sweet though what she said it's like
it just sounds so sweet and so like it's
not like it's so young like you're like
there's a monster in the bedroom and
like you're just like oh you're covering
your eyes yeah I just yeah because you
know it's funny in a lot of our work and
I could I still could be wrong and I
mean that very sincerely I say this with
humility I thought my mom and I had like
an inappropriate like it was like like
she was in love with me and I was in
love with her certainly because I was a
little boy and
um which by the way she said that at one
point because I told her all this I was
like you know I think maybe this got
blurred like yes Dad wasn't real really
showing up emotionally so we leaned on
each other a little too much and you
know what she said she said well my
therapist says you were in love with me
it was like what the [__] is happening I
was like I was
I was saying I barely like you
but you that is right so here's here's
oh but then but with more work to your
point about it being like a little girl
I think it it might be more father it
might be more she lost her dad pretty
early and I think she was looking for
more of a father because it was never
like gazing and holding hand it wasn't
like that it was more like will you save
oh I see I see and even in that
conversation that's what was happening
it was like we can you help me feel
better and I was happy to try and I do
want you to know this after that stuff I
was like we can't rely on our bodies I
did go this is just a fear of phone call
and I it's not and I was like I can tell
you're not in the mood for the
metaphysics maybe let's just talk about
how shitty it is to have Parkinson's you
know that's what we did yeah yeah
um I have a tangential thought so please
this is like one of my musings that make
me happy yeah and so I I'm not saying
it's true it just makes me happy yeah so
the reason why
it is more acceptable in society
for women to be lovers
instead of men to be lovers
I think this is much more of a stigma
for home for homosexuality than
lesbianism yeah I hear it's not that
lesbian yeah it's also homosexual I know
you mean gay men are stigmatized more
yeah and the reason is
is if if it would be different
if men lactate it that's where I got
this thought I've said this on stage you
did I got it from you oh great that's
what the money was for these are my bits
now
I go if you go if a woman licks a boob
that's still the second boob she's
licked that's right even if it's your
first that's right I got that from you I
didn't know I did I never did on a
special
but but I took that right from you oh
good I'm gonna call up writers in it's
not a good time it's not a good time not
a good time they're a bigger fish so
he'll be like he took something from one
of our sessions all right here's the
other here's the other musing just since
yeah yeah since you didn't ask I didn't
mean to take your punchline
that one's stuck with me that makes me
very happy about it it's also the second
vagina because you come out of a vagina
you're a lot you'll keep making it even
bigger okay not bigger yeah so
so the other uh part is
um
I Just Lose It
oh Jesus it's right here
uh I always have something all right you
want something go ahead because you know
what that made me I don't know if we
ever talked about this but I thought you
were gonna say
in this country we hate things that get
invaded and women uh so we look down on
women obviously there's a lot of
misogyny goddamn women so much uh and
what it's in our language to go go get
[__] [__] yourself like we don't like
things that get so gay men with being
you know penetrated lesbians it's way
safer they're in beer commercials is
what I'm saying that's right because no
one's getting penetrated no that's a
good one they're just like Coors Light
and there's just like two twins in a
bikini and you're like and they [__]
like that's the implication yeah like
let's name it this is a this is a sexual
fantasy these girls are into each other
even though they're twins it's so
[__] weird but that's why that's more
that's why the SNL commercial Schlitz
gay was so funny because you'll just
never see it
Michael Shea had a great joke I mean
it's a little cheeky but he goes I don't
want a gay son and he and he lets
everybody sit with that and he goes I
also don't want a straight daughter I
just don't want anyone [__] my kid
and I was like that is naming what we're
talking about for some reason we we only
in the western Society we only like
things that impose that invade that take
we don't like things that yield receive
there's no room for that I mean there
there's obviously no no micro climates
that's good but as a country that's good
we invade countries we drill oil we jizz
it all over yes Alaska yes we burn it we
eat it we hunt it we kill it we don't
want to what what make a joke be like oh
is that hemp milk milk Great British
Bake Off this is you just got me started
why is baking so feminine eggs milk oven
it's writ large it's it it just is it's
it's your mommy is pulling out cooked
parts of other animals Reaper I'm not
trying to ruin it I'm just saying no no
it's literally eggs and milk baby food
and babies
you know what I mean you know a
comforting warm nutrient dense it's
basically breast milk in a cake yes and
that's why we're more comfortable with
it isn't that fascinating that here you
know you are in your 40s I'm in my 60s
and these these aspects are still
powerful in play yes it's like you know
as as smart and evolved as I think I am
all of a sudden you know I'm just you
know I'm just sitting there and just
like a monkey you know you know sitting
there masturbating it's like what the f
what you you're nailing what's going on
you're DG Pig all over the place and I
love it this is a this is a good example
of
what I hear you saying is we are
susceptible to these things and it's
helpful just to name them I'm not I'm
not putting a value judgment on baking
having a feminine energy yeah obviously
men do it it's it's there's no judgment
there it's just an observation it's
helpful to my own filing cabinet of my
psyche to just go like I recognize that
similarly here at this house that you
walk through I remember Val was making
dinner and she we one of our guy friends
was staying with us and I came home
and by the way I no pop-up you used to
call those pop-ups I'm not going to
clear my throat I'm just going to say
what happened okay good I came in and
Val and this guy who we both love
we're like Barefoot together in the
kitchen making dinner and listen to the
language here in my kitchen
right yeah I understand this is
possessive it's not very it's but it's
very human but it that's that's what
that's what you do is you just said
instead of going
well that's that's your friend and he
was making you dinner you know he said
you just went I I it probably took me 45
minutes to tell you that story all the
conflicting feelings I feel bad and I
feel bad that I feel bad I feel
possessive I feel like get out of here
like Odysseus I'm like what is this a
Suitor like [__] get out of here and
you just went
it's the wrong Optics yeah that's all
you said it's again it's very erotic
it's the wrong wrong Optics or these
very specific languages that don't even
endorse or condemn yes they're just sort
of labeling
for me
and let's look at all the factors coffee
food how'd my day go how many little
assaults to my ego did I Endure was it
15 too many micro things yes someone
cutting you in line at the airport
someone gives you a look or just me
looking in the mirror
God damn yes like what a micro assault
what happened what happened yeah exactly
yes it we're so fragile so fragile sorry
to keep talking about psychedelics but I
took a micro dose of LSD once it was
very little but you know people do that
and I I was in the car if I was driving
obviously she wasn't done anything and I
just drove down the highway with her and
I was like I could feel in my body every
time someone just rightfully not rudely
merged in front of my body like you'd
feel it all these things that we ignore
this is powerful lesson in like life is
so much harder than we think it is and
you are so much more vulnerable and
susceptible even me just like this like
look I'm not saying we need to all
become
super vulnerable that we're paralyzed
yes but we can recognize that even me
lunging forward or raising my voice like
uh if you were really in tune with your
body you would go like wow like there's
a part of you that's keeping you safe
yes and it doesn't know and it doesn't
know that that guy isn't having sex with
my wife in that moment get the [__] out
of here oh I'll eat this all right you
know what I mean like yes you just green
lit
greenlit that that's right and it
doesn't
get better as we age
it's like it's just it just doesn't get
better it's like
oh God like I was a God you know I had
hair and I had this and my joints were
all solid and great and yeah and then
all our friends have you know what do
they have someone's got this and someone
needs back surgery and someone needs
this and it's just and but this but the
point is it's getting us ready
it's kind of getting us ready to
transcend our bodies well that's what I
was trying to say to my mom which by the
way still glad that I let it go because
sometimes you're just not in the mood
for that and sometimes ramdas would say
you just have to go that sucks yeah yeah
but I'm with you
and don't get me wrong sometimes I don't
want to hear it but most of the time I
take great comfort in going like
it's in Fight Club they go the Mona Lisa
has fallen apart too like it's all it's
Buddhist this cup is already broken this
guy's already dead
you're already dead there's a great
comfort in there but it's it's really
smart and it's very like evolved
yet when I'm getting results from blood
work when I go to the doctor or
something
and they're calling me to tell me yeah
I it is impossible
it is impossible for me to have my heart
rate be slow that's right can I that
that's so helpful my great teacher David
nichteren who's a one of my friends
who's also a teacher he he's always
reminding me relative truth absolute
truth he's like absolute truth we're
both already dead relative truth I hope
my blood results are okay that's right
that's good I like that I get a little
too yeah what are you on about it's all
over it's starting to happen we're all
the same star stuff from the furthest
planet and the furthest Galaxy where all
this is who we are well you know what
enables me to have that world view too
is those experiences that I've had where
I'm like it's already done it's already
done meaning yeah everything's okay
that's right and that makes me and that
makes me happy I mean it makes it it
makes me happy to look at the deep space
field
to know the enormity why it makes me
happy it doesn't you know
I think I think like this is I think
there's no death because as as a Newton
tells us we can't energy can't be
created or destroyed
we're only transformed yeah
this episode guys very appropriately is
brought To Us by our friends at
betterhelp as you can see Getting to
Know Yourself is a process it takes help
it takes guidance it takes mentorship it
takes expertise and as you can tell from
this conversation talk therapy is more
powerful than the sum of its parts it
seems like you're just chatting with
somebody but when that somebody is a
trained professional they have a way of
guiding you and helping you through some
of the biggest toughest stuff in life
like before I went to therapy to see Dr
Gary Ben as you're listening to I didn't
know what codependency was or how to end
a relationship in a healthy way as we're
discussing or set up boundaries with my
family with friends even It's Tricky
stuff and that's what therapy is all
about deepening your self-awareness and
your understanding and equipping you
with those life skills that literally
make your life better and more easy to
navigate because sometimes we don't know
what we want or why we react the way we
do until we talk things through and
better help connects you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are because the more you know about
yourself the more easily you can
maneuver through life with less
suffering and more clarity for
relationships grief loss anxiety you
name it talking about it with a
professional helps as you can hear it
makes a difference so if you're thinking
of starting therapy I think that's
wonderful give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so you can dial it in
just right with the right person
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com weirdo today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-petterhelp.com
weirdo also in my Arsenal for anxiety
and overwhelm I'm holding it up for the
video I'm shaking it for the audio these
are Pym choose prepare your mind they
taste amazing they're sugar-free I love
it they help you manage feelings of
stress anxiety and overwhelm if you're
like me you might be a little bit
skeptical about a tasty little Citrus
flavored chew that can help with those
things but when I first tried bym chews
no joke not reading a script here it
made me feel so calm and confident and
locked into my body in a cozy and good
way I subscribed immediately and got
subscriptions from my mother and my
brother I was like look we're all wired
the same we need help it's wonderful
when you're feeling worried stressed out
or you just have that b in your belly
that won't settle down you just chew two
of these delicious naturally flavored no
sugar I had to choose and in minutes you
start to feel more centered calm and in
control I like to take it at the start
of my day to ease me into whatever I'm
about to do sometimes I can't face my
inbox take some Pym choose gets me in
that below or I take them at the end of
the day to wind down and let go of the
stress that I accrued accrued during my
activity how does it work Pym choose are
comprised of proven amino acid complexes
and adaptogens that help support your
brain and your body's ability to
organically support and manage and
tolerate stress anxiety and overwhelm so
these are proven compounds that can help
your body do what it is designed to do I
take it along every day with their mood
magnesium over like 75 are deficient in
magnesium and their mood magnesium
includes three magnesiums with the most
evidence to support their effects on
stress and sleep very effective in
helping you fall asleep fast and stay
asleep through the night
and a percentage of all of their profits
one percent goes towards mental health
non-profits including the great one
bring change to mind so help your body
and your mind fight off stress anxiety
and overwhelm and added bonus sleep more
deeply with Pym seriously a game changer
go to you can pym.com weird and use
promo code weird for 15 off that's you
can
pym.com slash weird promo code weird for
15 off all right everybody let's get
back to the second half of Dr Gary Penn
so I'm going to give you one of my
musings you'll tell me what you think
about it
and I just go I've been doing that on
stage for six months
I forgot I stole that from you so here's
one of my musings hit it
why someone's a transsexual a lot of
suppositions
in their last life
this boy was a girl
hmm
he gets
he gets reincarnated a lot of
suppositions last life reincarnation and
you have a memory trace of your of your
own sex yeah because a lot of people who
are that's really interesting who are
transsexual they go I knew since I was
like three like when you're three do you
really think to yourself oh this is my
penis you don't even know where it's
like a little I'm gonna play with it
it's this what it is what it is but
you're not thinking like of course I
have a penis right
yes or as my my last analyst said to me
Gary you're looking for happiness I'm
sorry
happiness yeah so those of you who
didn't get it so anyway so they keep a
they keep a a memory Trace
and the reason is in their last life
they were female and they looked down
they go I'm in the wrong body
[Music]
so that makes sense that these like
these things make me happy it could
right to be total BS right it's just
it's a thought experiment yeah it's a
thought experience I'm with you I'm with
you that is very interesting to consider
and also it reminds me of those stories
you know in India a girl is born and
she's going where's my husband you hear
these stories where's my husband where's
my husband oh interesting and they go he
was murdered little this is a true story
it's in a book called Life After Life I
think oh it's just a book of
reincarnation stories okay I actually
don't recommend it it's deeply academic
and I didn't like it yeah but this story
was good
um meaning it's you know it's all
footnote it's like it's like reading a
textbook
but the story is this little girl goes
um
she accused someone in the village of
murdering her husband little girl can
you imagine how off-putting that is that
is a six-year-old is like yeah that guy
killed my husband yeah and they're like
what are you talking about she's like he
hit him over the head
uh this that obviously was before I was
born
um with it let's I'm gonna make the
story a little better like let's say it
was with a hatchet okay and then he
buried him over here and they went over
there and they dug it up and there was a
skeleton with a hatchet in his head and
it was this guy and his his wife had
died as well and she was reincarnating
that you get the story that's the
punchline that's a great one let's go
back to
um something that is a little bit more
on Earth
the narcissism thing yeah I I'm noticing
that that's helping thou I'm this
in great part thanks to you this like
I've gotten in touch with like it's okay
to be smart it's okay yes to be driven
yes it's okay I'm not being an [__]
it's more than okay it's terrific it's
terrific even you saying that now yeah
it makes me feel good it's really
terrific it's it's terrific that you're
you know compassionate and you're and
you're this and you're then you're and
you love your wife yes it's great and
then Val is uh on the Enneagram she's in
I don't know if you know the Enneagram
she's a nine which is a peacekeeper and
she mirrors people a lot and my favorite
people are nines
um just really groovy wonderful people
but she's learning how to be I'm a three
and a four three is an achiever and a
four is an individualist and I'm right
in the middle but she's learning how to
find her three Ness her threeness there
you go
her threeness uh
and it's beautiful to watch and it's and
it's sort of
it's an echo of what you did for me I do
for her and she doesn't she listens to
me one out of five times where it's like
just cancel
you know what I mean yeah you don't want
to go yeah that that friend and I was
going to listen to this this isn't a
secret
that friend uh stresses you out just
just say I I can't tonight yeah my
friend goes no is a complete sentence
you know that thing is like no I can't I
like that I gotta I gotta bounce but
like it's I also love her tenderness and
her softness and I love that she's not
like me I wouldn't want to date or be
married to someone that's like me but
the example is this is I I'd love to
just launch this into you uh launch this
into you Dr Freud
we were driving to Leela's school from
La though uh so this is an hour and a
half away okay she had to pee the whole
time but to be on time she held it like
the last 20 minutes she was like I
really gotta pee but I'm gonna hold it I
was like okay got to school I get out of
the car I run in to get Lee Val people I
told this with Julia Dreyfus but Val
runs into another mom and I immediately
go she's not gonna pee I just
immediately know she's going to Pride
and it's beautiful she's going to
prioritize the social interaction with
this woman and I go and get Leela
this takes 10 minutes I get her I sign
her out I walk out Val's still talking
to this mom and I just go Val has to pee
thou has to pee I'm sorry it's over we
love you Val has to pee and I'm
literally pushing her
I just feel like you'll agree that is
this is spectacular spectacular it is
spectacular and that's you taught me how
to do that it's okay it's so simple but
it's but but the thing is it's
spectacular and it's like there's not it
doesn't make sense that it's spectacular
but it is spectacular right nobody's
yelling no one yelling shut the [__] up
yeah what the hell yeah no I'm doing
that no it's not me I do it at hangs
dinners I I know it's it's a little bit
strange but sometimes I get social
anxiety or whatever it is I'm just
feeling uncomfortable I've learned to
just go this is done I say it it's like
a joke it makes people laugh I go this
hang is over and everyone laughs but
like go ahead and laugh I'm glad we're
laughing yes but it's also my truth this
hang is over Val has to pee and and
again not talking about genders
necessarily but it's masculine and it's
beautiful that's right it is masculine
and it is
so I'm so glad we're talking about this
Pete because like in the last like five
or six months
I've been talking about narcissism so
much in my work I've been talking I I
give supervision to a couple of
therapists and
I keep on one in particular I keep on
telling her to
you have to be narcissist you have to
embrace your narcissism another man
who's sweetest guy in the world but
always you know can I is it okay if I
Gary can I ask you a question yeah and I
you know I'd say
knock it off and just say you know if
you would stop the pop-up yeah just like
stop
and he's starting to be powerful his
career is exploding and when and my my
my the person I'm giving supervision to
her work is getting so much more
powerful and and people are so much more
responsive and people are moving the
narcissism
it's it's a neutral word
it's not negative it's neutral it's like
okay what however you want narcissistic
personality disorder it's just
narcissism it's about having a sense of
I'm powerful I have something to say I
have something to offer you I can look
at my reflection in the leg it's pretty
it's okay I'm not gonna the disorder is
I only look at it that's right but it's
also a disorder to never look at it
that's right right that's right that's
right it reminds me of Narcissus and
Goldman if you read that from Hermann
has no back in the day back in Bedrock
it's a it's a it's a great book but I
okay am I right in it saying it's
arguing that there needs to be a little
bit yes
you know again
Val's narcissism valves looking at her
own reflection saying this person
deserves to not feel uncomfortable and
have to pee yes I have to pee that's
right and that is it's not being a piece
of [__] it's not being a piece of [__]
and it's just just because you're not
nice doesn't mean you're being mean and
it's just like this thing of it's just
yeah like what we do to ourselves like
disproving negatives yeah I don't want
you to think
and the the goal of the goal of therapy
in general at least the way I look at it
Freud said it as well so I don't know I
probably would have thought of it anyway
men have nipples
is to make the unconscious conscious
yeah and Freud said if you make the
unconscious conscious you're able to
work in love well
and I thought that was smart but if you
make the unconscious conscious so when
you're unconscious and you're making
excuses and then you notice it and you
go oh how interesting that I'm doing
this again yes or how interesting that
I'm I'm I'm having trouble saying that
you know I gotta go pee yes because that
that is you going through a wormhole all
of a sudden a person who's 50 years old
loses a decade loses a decade you just
go through this Wormhole and you're back
in 1980 or something that's right how
did that happen right sorry they both
very lovingly saw me looking for a pen
but I know what I was going to say one
was big boobs and one was
um Iron John have you I'm have you read
iron John
such a long time yeah because it came
out in like the 60s yeah but he talks
about these men's Retreats where one of
the things he would have the men do is
pick up a sword like they had a sword
and just like kind of a king arth an
Arthurian yeah just to start the day
nice hold it up yeah just take up space
and hold us we're not going to kill
anything this isn't violent it's just
we're just gonna go huzzah like what
like uh well when we're gonna barbaric
yup yeah right yeah and he was like the
number of men that couldn't do it
because this was
you know this the 60s and the 70s
obviously was a beautiful time and it
was when we started kind of
being a little bit more embarrassed of
that stuff I would say rightfully so
that's my opinion is some of this I
think I think you need to be tamed
you're absolutely right which I think by
the way this is
going on what you said is that
um this is why men these days are so
broken I think men are having the
biggest problems in the last like 40 50
years you know Women are Smarter than we
are they're more therapized than we are
they're more college educated they're
more even in math and other things and
men are just like kind of you know since
they did you know fiber optics under the
Atlantic
all the jobs that they had that gave
them a lot of our population self-esteem
I could work at the at the plant in
Akron Ohio I could get make a good
living I had union wages and I had and I
had you know double time and
it's all gone I could get a little cabin
in the lake I could feel like a man
taking care of my family right right
and now it's all gone and men are just
lost these days
and then I have him go let me know if
you need me to lift anything heavy which
is what you're saying yeah and I even as
you're saying it yeah I know in modern
times I there's a there's an Impulse for
me as the host and wanting to look good
to be like not that that's on
so men can do but I'm saying for me yes
I know what you're talking about and and
I can be honest with Val about that the
conquest yes and it does inform our
sexuality if I go in close or kill what
do we call comedy I killed yes I I mean
if they tied a deer on my car when I
left the comedy store I wouldn't be like
get that deer off of there you should be
so lucky to feel how a comedian feels
leaving I I have to admit I've never
done cocaine I think it must be like it
insane it is isn't it amazing when
you're on stage and you just have them
in your paw and you know but it's
essential I think a lot of my mental
health Believe It or Not people talk
about the sad clown and of course he's a
drug addict and of course they killed
themselves all this sort of stuff I know
there's a lot of mentally ill people in
in comedy there's also like
whatever they're prescribing it's a
thousand times better for me I'm talking
about like Xanax sure sure things
anti-anxiety and depression I go up on
stage and I'm heard and I'm in I get the
sense of being in control and you're
loved and I'm loved let's be yeah that's
that's a feeling for sure yeah yeah and
you changed reality yes you imposed you
were not imposed what what do comedians
call you bomb you also say I died I'm
dying up here so you either kill or you
die yes so the my well-balancedness and
my Valentine joke all the time that I'm
70 30 feminine you know I don't know the
exact numbers but one of the reasons I'm
so comfortable with that is because I
have a deeply masculine practice that I
get to
I don't want to vilify it and say
exercise it that makes it sound like a
demon I get to exercise that I get to go
out and do it and Val loves it one time
I told a crowd
[__] you never go to a comedy club again
and and she couldn't have been more
turned on and I said good night it was
after doing an hour stand up and I hated
them and I went nice [__] you never go
to a comedy club again I walked off
stage and they played Kanye West can't
tell me nothing and Val couldn't she she
still talks about it yeah and I was like
what a gift but again yes I missed her I
told you about how embodied I'm trying
to be and and and and how evolved I'm
trying to be I'm all for it yes but it's
this little thing that we're not really
talking about very much is I'm like
want to know why I'm so comfortable
saying I'm 70 30 phone is because I get
to go out and I'm not hunting but I feel
like I'm hunting my psyche thinks I come
home covered in blood and that's why I'm
blasting yes uh Kendrick Lamar in the
car and it makes sense only it makes
perfect this music makes sense that's
right you know what I mean that's right
like I understand that I listen to like
Battle Raps like people dissing each
other and I'm like yeah yeah [__] get
it
then I go home and I hold my daughter
and I'm better for it I'm I'm a sorry
I'm on a no no I'm like I'm liking this
put Rouge on me I'll wear it whatever
you want of a dolly tea party I'm all
about it I'm as gentle as a as a as a
breeze with my daughter and and I and
then Daddy gets to go and do this thing
and I think that's sort of maybe a
little bit underreported in in the
Modern Age
I I think so I think that um
only a man who is very
at peace with his masculinity could say
I'm 70 30 feminine yeah so it's just
proving you're right your masculinity
right which is the whole polite no you
know what's funny sorry do you have more
no no no no no no no no that's good
that's good no keep on going I'm gonna
put this thought to you being a man is
tricky as [__] this is what I mean by
that I was gonna write this as a joke
list all the drugs I've done
pot LSD mushrooms DMT ketamine whatever
it is and then go you know what the
biggest the craziest drug I've ever done
is testosterone
it really is for me if you want to talk
about something that's like going to
reveal something like you know you take
mushrooms and you're like it's going to
take me on a spirit Quest testosterone
is uh a [__] meaning just the
past couple years everyone knows I'm
going to say this I just started lifting
weights why do I mention that I think
it's quadrupled my testosterone and you
wouldn't believe I understand every
werewolf movie I understand every
monster story and I understand my father
yes and it's scary as [__] talk about
Luke going in the cave and it's you it's
you in the mess and I go oh I have to
bite my tongue I have to excuse myself I
have to go I can't talk about this right
now because inside I'm the Hulk I I
don't mean muscularly my body's pretty
much the same but I've started getting
and it does feel like having a sword and
nobody taught me how to use it you know
what I'm saying so this is this is just
more to load on to you uh and what it
makes you think of
it's
it's well what I was thinking about as
you were talking is
it is so it is so human like I I feel
really great right now like you've been
so generous with me you've been so kind
to me you've been so complimentary
it feels great it does I mean it's just
a big thing I'm like why don't we do it
to each other why don't we give it away
give it away if I could just run down
your street like naked I talk about that
on Saturday it's Joy is so easy yes what
are we doing trying to raise the stock
on our praise yeah or by withholding it
or yeah or by saying oh whatever it
doesn't affect me like it it feels great
yeah and when one of the people I work
with say Gary you know
when you said when we started today you
said you know you changed my life like
what yeah you you couldn't give me a
better gift like
you're sitting there and you have you
meet someone and you have 50 minutes at
a time and you wonder like do I make a
difference am I yeah am I am I gonna be
remembered is this something and you say
oh you have hundreds of kids I'm
imagining
and you gave me this gift yeah and it it
just feels good doesn't it it's gonna
feel good for a long time but it feels
good for me too that is the weird yes
giving is receiving is whatever that's
right and that is that is masculine and
it's powerful and you're saying I'm
Gonna Make You free great thank you for
saying that because you just married it
to what we were saying before too is
like it's not masculine
for us to go up the mountain and go like
keep up boy you know what I mean which
is what we think masculinity is yes but
it's so talk about
[__] imposing what imposes more than
love or praise yes or encouragement or
like I noticed
you you did that pretty good I can't do
that yes like that's [__] why is that
it's not just that's not feminine that
doesn't mean you've done something
feminine you can that's still yes in
your power yes and it brings up you know
when I when I grew up
I had such shitty parents such really
awful parents that if you couldn't do
something right
the only thing I knew to do was to make
fun of you hmm and to this moment I'm
writing my second book it's um
I still can't believe my life came to
this no no no no I still can't I still
can't believe my life has come to this
the first one's gone I can't believe my
life has come to them it's the working
title right now is a little bit better
it's great
um because one of my things I like to
say is I try to be a little better today
than I was yesterday and a little better
tomorrow than I am today yeah but I I
I'm kind of haunted by the shitty things
I've done um
I feel like you know Jacob Marley
you know wandering like oh from
Christmas A Christmas Carol Christmas
Carol yeah making you know people feel
bad yeah by the way I'm sorry I just
want you in this moment I was just
thinking about this yesterday we all act
like we're all going around
everything's fine hello I've always I've
been kind in every situation yes and we
can't get enough of movies where
something's Chasing You something's
gonna kill you you're guilty you're
murdered there's haunted houses there's
literally people under the floorboards
there's zombies and demons and we love
these movies and we flock to them and we
need them and those same people are not
everybody but you know on the record in
the lights and you talk to them they'll
tell you that they're they're not
embarrassed of their past they're not
ashamed of of mistakes because there's
no room for it it's like in a social
media world it's like yes no then why
then why is the number one genre right
now horror if I want to sell a comedy
right now I have to be like and there's
a clown who who has a sickle like that's
the only way nice what's going on yeah
which is it we're all golden children
right or we're deathly afraid of the
blood in the elevator I think it's the
blood in the yellow I think so I think I
think we know that it's there and we're
still we want to be told that it's okay
okay yes terrible parents make fun of
people when they when they stink yeah I
interrupted no it's it's it's but that's
it's it's such a it's such a that's
when you were saying like to it's very
masculine too so my sense of masculinity
was toxic I see right part of part of my
growth is being married to like a kind
loving person and you go oh
oh like that's that's a possibility yeah
like so you learn like you sit there and
you you don't even realize it like it's
kind of like like through osmosis like
all of a sudden I'm going oh like nice
yeah this is nice and she's you know
we're both gonna cry down because I'm
thinking about Val and the grace of
finding a vow yeah that's right and and
you had a lot to opening up to that
possibility like when I wrote down boobs
we'll get to that but like
ah sorry I sort of lost the thought but
like when you when you meet someone
who's kind oh they're re-parenting you
yes I used to think it was so weird that
people call their partner's mama I call
Val Mama all the time do you really
because it started with Leela I'd go do
you want Mama now I'm just like hey Mama
and I I go like [__] just own it just
just be fine with it who's your Daddy
yeah well dude I used to have that as a
joke I go the whole thing's Freudian yes
you're you're calling him poppy he's
calling you Mama yes and you're trying
to cram yourself into your first
apartment yeah that's good I mean it's
so [__] obvious yes
that that it's hidden yes right so let's
just laugh about it it's okay but like I
feel her uh again my parents I'm not
just saying this did the best they could
did a great job and they're the parts
that needed to be repaired I'm
re-parenting them I say to that
six-year-old I got you yes don't worry
yes and Val's got you that's that's
another
thing going on so let me tell you
talk about how emotional it is to think
about
the potential of these Partners think of
where I was when I saw you and the hand
you had in in being open and receptive
to somebody like them
was Val is a curvy woman she's a sexy
woman
and that I swear to God when I first
started seeing you was something that I
was uncomfortable with
that because I had I have a joke about
it it's on um
it's on one of the specials uh I used to
joke when you introduce that to your
parents you have to say this is what I'm
into
it's overt
there's a smoke screen of dating someone
who looks like what you think about the
classic beautiful woman in American
culture beautiful but doesn't not not
overly sexual you know so you can bring
her home yes and when somebody's sexy or
or let's just name it big boobs you're
like I like big boobs that's [__]
embarrassing I couldn't even green light
that I'm saying
that wasn't the most powerful we can
take masculine feminine it just wasn't I
wasn't standing in my power I wasn't
being honest yeah and I started dating
Val when when you and I were together
yes when you and I were together but you
know what I mean and you and I used to
be like
I'd tell you that feeling and you'd be
like again who cares sounds great yeah
and I say this when we talk about
therapy all the time it's greater than
the sum of its parts it wasn't just my
doctor saying that's great it was an
archetype it was a again a man who's
older than me saying you belong in the
tribe I know what you mean that's
beautiful I'm glad that's what you want
it it kills me my God told me you know
it wasn't a real God
don't masturbate don't be sexual if
there's a girl with big boobs run away
jerk off come back and be ashamed be
ashamed yes and then ask her friend out
because she looks like you know Winnie
Cooper from The Wonder Years Don't date
the sexy one remember in The Wonder
Years there was the sexy one who's the
who's Madeline or something it was
it's the two types it's Angel Horicon
yeah I keep on thinking of Winnie Cooper
who always look like she always looked
like she had indigestion yeah she yeah
she she had an interesting look going on
like she was like she either had like a
hemorrhoid or anything yeah she wasn't
uncomfortable yeah
and then and then and then the thing is
now just once if you want to get into
Winnie Cooper yeah I do we got no I
didn't mean it that way
we got very my wife and I got very
addicted to Hallmark Christmas movies
good for you so we would just be like
sitting there yes eating like you know
mac and cheese by the way does anything
sound like love more Val and I we joke
that we're like lesbians we watch
Blossom we just throw on like old
sitcoms that's love if somebody says me
and my wife make popcorn and watch
Blossom or Hallmark Christmas movies I
go this is a Mitzvah what a what a joy
I'm so glad you found your person yeah
you know it's true that's true so just
so you know Winnie is now on like
ten percent of the Christmas movies oh
and she still looks like she has
indigestion every time I can't find
someone yeah
and it's Christmas
what am I going to do of course she ends
up yeah buying someone yeah the parade
leader or whatever yeah whatever it is
yeah it's so beautiful yeah but but you
really
specifically told me it was okay the
things we don't know are okay that that
is the top that topic the things we
don't know are okay it's okay to break
up with somebody by the way do you know
the end of that story I had the list
tell me this is when I was seeing you in
Santa Monica it's a long drive from here
Brentwood Brentwood forgive me it's all
the same yes to me Brentwood is Santa
Monica to me
um which by the way reminds me I tried
to get Judd to see you and I think I
think he was scared to see you because I
was like yeah he's Fierce and Judd was
like I don't know I don't know like I
was like no he's not gonna take any of
your [__] he was like I'm not sure I
don't think he ever called you you don't
you don't have to speak on them well I
was confident he did not oh now I'm mad
at him so if he's listening I won't even
see you if you no if you beg that's so
funny yeah and now we've turned the
tables yeah but I'm driving back I go to
okay so there's three parts of the story
part one I was so torn up about this
relationship that I called The Writer's
room I was in everyone was passing
around this number of a psychic and it
was a tarot card psychic in New York
which I think is really interesting
because we're calling her from La this
is before I'm famous so there's no
Googling there's no
but you know there's no tricks yeah at
least that I can tell I just got the
number and I called her we set up an
appointment
called her so I emailed her like what I
don't know what happened who [__]
cares I got on the phone with this woman
real kook
but right on the money I've told the
story a million times she said who's bug
I called my girlfriend at the time Boog
not a common nickname short for booger
wow she goes who's bug one of the first
things she said we were not writing bug
on each other's Facebook walls that's
important there was no bug yeah it's
[__] crazy also what kind of lunatic
for forty dollars is gonna do that deep
of a day you know what I mean yeah yeah
so she's just going who's bug and she
said after I said let's talk about love
then she goes there's someone on the
other side who is pulling for you
because she goes this almost looks like
love that's what she said which is just
haunting when you really want it to work
she goes this almost looks like love oh
yes isn't that just yes breaks my heart
yeah even as I'm saying it I'm glad that
didn't yeah yeah last but you're on the
clock you don't know it yet but you are
yeah exactly it broke my heart
and then she goes um
she kind of implied you know what you
need to do
and she goes there's someone on the
other side
uh on your side of the family trying
pulling for you to do the right thing I
didn't know what that meant
I couldn't figure out who it was might
have been my Uncle Larry I don't know
somebody who just passed
then I go and see you this is part two
you say you don't need a list
you're very fervent about this not you
don't raise your voice or anything
you're just like what are you doing
you can just say I'm gonna bounce I
don't believe you though
I'm driving the part three I'm driving
home this isn't safe but I'm in traffic
I take out my phone that's where the
note is and I open the note it was under
something covert
because I didn't want her to find it God
forbid long ass less yeah one of the
things on the list is snoops on my phone
so I'm I think of another reason to
break up with her even though you just
told me yeah and even though this the
psychic tells me there's someone pulling
for you on the other side I open my
phone I start typing in the note and the
phone goes black
it's never happened before since phone
just turns off okay
reboots
everything's normal on the phone except
that note was deleted
isn't that crazy
that's trippy trippy everything was
there yeah yeah that note was deleted
crazy and I was like that to me
I don't know how to call it literally
but I was like that felt like another a
person on the other side going like he's
right and I think we broke up pretty
shortly after that I think I used a line
that you gave me which was
I tried to just be as blunt as possible
and the sun's uncaring I'm not saying
this in a I'm not beating my chest I'm
saying to people
in situations where you can't figure it
out sometimes you have to say it very
plainly and it's not mean but it's not
nice I said I don't want to marry you I
don't want to have kids with you and
that I had to say it yeah it hurts me to
say it now but I had to name it
say exactly what you mean because I
think this person thinks you're just
playing cat and mouse like yes I'm gonna
break up with you yeah I was like no
really I've thought about this it's so
true because you can't say like I'm
thinking that maybe you know we should
think about like you did people like I
had are so uncomfortable saying I'm done
like this is I'm not gonna marry you
you're not going to give you you're not
going to have kids with you like when
you give someone really tough news
there's obviously exceptions
but I almost always coach them to say
give them the bad news first
um
I'm breaking up with you right it's over
I'm gonna move on and then why I could
tell you why but this is this is this is
not negotiable this this is my truth
right
and it makes things a lot easier I think
for everybody yeah it just like we we
know how the story ends
yeah and I've I've moved on but again
it's like
living living an actualized life and I'm
not saying that I'm actualized or I must
actualized as I am as are you
but it's a hero's journey yes it is an
absolute hero's journey it is
it is it is it is lonely sometimes
you know as you go along the bell curve
which we talked about before you get
lonelier and lonelier and lonelier
but it's
it's a great journey I mean the the win
is amazing because you're starting worth
it it's worth it because it's like
we're not we're not gripping all the
time yeah we're expansive like the goal
is to be expansive that's not
constrictive you're gonna I think you're
gonna love this they it was on when
Letterman I think interviewed Jay-Z
Jay-Z said my friends say sometimes
friends I grew up with say you've
changed
and I say hell yeah I've changed you
think I did all that work to stay the
same and I was like God damn it that's
DGP all the way that's right it's like
yes yes that's something else you taught
me is concede the point that's right
they go you'll regret this I might
regret this that's right
it's also true I might regret this I
don't know how I'll feel that's right I
might and so what's the what's what's
the crime I might regret it and then
I'll come back and then I'll say I'll go
[__] I messed up of course in my mind
I'm like
uh
right
I regret it people tell me you know when
one of the things that we do in therapy
is some people are so defensive like
when you argue
and I say almost always accept the
supposition
Gary you're judgmental
um
I could be judgmental why are you
telling me this uh Gary you're a racist
I'm sure I have racism in me like uh
right why are you saying this yeah yeah
getting curious what do you mean but but
accept the supposition you think you're
better than me sometimes I do yeah but
people say I don't think I'm better than
you or you're the one and they'll argue
they'll have a fight give them the
Dignity of like I I know I can be that
way yeah yeah but that doesn't mean I am
being that way I say why are you saying
this unless it's very obvious yeah right
it's less but accept the supposition and
our life becomes so much easier and all
of a sudden we level up immensely
because how often do we argue and have
fights over nothingness well in that
situation if she goes you're being
selfish you're gonna go I am being
selfish yeah I'm looking out for myself
right now right that's yes Gary you're
being defensive I'm not defensive yeah
yeah oh right but that goes back to what
Freud said you know it's like
making the unconscious conscious and how
many of our dreams I have those dreams
obviously one of my bigger fears is that
there's a there's a rage in me right
that's why I've I'm so forward with my
hooray for everythingness and when I
feel it it frightens me and like getting
into a place where you can go like you
you have that rage and I've seen it
and it's
we fish about one time in a parking lot
but it was for money but it's so it's
it's so important
you sound just like Val yes I mean it's
it's your protector but it's more than
that it's such a great part of you it's
I'm angry for the things that didn't
happen to me that should have or the
thing you know I'm just it's almost like
a sense of self-love in a way like don't
you dare say I'm not you know a good
person and
I don't know that's not very eloquent
but I'm just saying it's not it's not
like you're not gonna act like if I have
a fantasy of another woman who cares I'm
not acting yeah yeah I'm not acting out
right you're not you're not punching
people in the face you've helped me by
the way with that specifically with Val
it's like
not my Christian my former self my
formerly married self would act like no
one is beautiful no one is sexy to you
and it's really healthy yeah for both
ways I'm well aware that Valerie has a
crush on my friend Brett Goldstein and
that's okay and she knows I'm trying to
think of my person I don't even know who
Kat Dennings maybe
but like these babes and it's great when
they're on TV and go like there's your
girlfriend yeah some Avatar that
whatever exactly she because you know
what it is I know she's not leaving and
she knows I'm not that's right it's like
you're not playing with scared money
we're not playing with scared money so
we can get like silly with us that's
right I tell people all the time just
play good poker yeah whether you you
lose whether you get the inside straight
or whether someone to just make good
decisions Play Good poker yeah it would
be fine and don't be frightened and
there's a problem if you are frightened
I think right I mean like fear is the
problem it can be yeah that's right I
had other things there were so many
other things oh you know what else you
used to say to me
when I started getting more
success in my life and your life starts
to change
so I started seeing you before this is
the backdrop from the petone show and it
was before the petone show so you really
were there I remember you said it's like
you're standing on the beach and there's
a wave you can see it but it hasn't hit
you yet so we were already working
together for years before that happened
and then you ushered me through
and there was just so much of again this
here's the pop-up I'm worried this will
sound cruel but there are certain people
that didn't make the cut into the new
life and that doesn't mean they weren't
fancy enough because frankly I have
friends who are way more famous than me
and they caught me out and I'm like is
it because I'm not famous enough and
[__] you like I don't like that this is
just they didn't fit in the new
frequency yeah some of them maybe they
were like it was just too mean it was
this weird part of me
that didn't like myself that was
attracted to this person that told me I
was [__] something like that
things like that
and I'm telling you about I don't know
how to I didn't even know how to say I'm
reshaping my world I didn't know I was
and do you remember what you said you
said Microsoft fires the bottom five
percent oh right right no no it was GE
GE fires the bottom yeah you know it's
not funny you just said that because I
was thinking that about 20 seconds ago
Jack Welch he said every year he would
let go of the bottom ten percent ten
percent the bottom 10 and a lot of
people hated him for for that and he
he's kind of a douche but it doesn't
matter but but he would um
what what he would say is
it's not that I'm being cruel it's like
that wasn't the right job for them if
you're in the bottom 10 yeah this isn't
the right gig for you yeah so let's move
you to something else or you have to
find something else it's not like I hope
you just live on the streets and you you
know it's a trash can just because it
ends doesn't mean it was a failure it's
the same with the relationship yes right
this isn't working I'm gonna bounce yeah
it doesn't mean you suck right it
doesn't mean I hate you right I'm not
embarrassed there were good times you
changed my life in fact that woman I
swear to God I referred her as my
Jailbreaker because I didn't realize
that I was in these prisons uh in some
of my family structures and she shocked
me out of it she really did because she
was the beautiful thing about it was
that she was loud and brassy and in your
face and my family came and it didn't
work and it shook it up and it literally
blew a hole in the prison wall and then
I went out it and that seems kind of
cruel but it's also kind of like no that
was great I hope I broke some of your
walls too but in the end I think we're
going to go our separate ways it's the
bottom ten that's right yeah I remember
you saying that and again the things
people think are wrong going like the
Jay-Z thing I've changed I've changed I
don't want to be I don't want to smoke
cigarettes
and drink whiskey at 11 A.M it's that
that's what I used to do I don't want to
do it anymore and and he's he's leveled
up right Jay-Z oh I I don't know I meant
me yeah oh yeah no Jay-Z Nothing said he
said it but yeah but of course you've
leveled up yeah yeah yeah but it but it
was there was a time in my life it's a
self-love issue it's like this is what I
deserve I should be hungover I should be
bloated I should be
struggling like who am I to you know
step out it's it's this is a little
tangential but so many people have a
psychology of poverty like they're
afraid a lot of my my colleagues
are afraid to charge as much money as
they should yeah they're just terrified
like it means something it means like
they're greedy or it means like yeah
they don't care about their patience and
I'm saying now that not everyone's going
to pay your top fee but some people
could afford it and like it's expensive
to live in Los Angeles yeah they can't
do it yeah and there's a lot of them are
therapist they just can't do it and it's
like they're tortured by this idea of
what I deserve right maybe that's back
to the sense of narcissism like
this is if you do this just take care of
it I I can still so father Greg Boyle
you know Homeboy Industries he did his
pod and I just I was kind of hard that
week on stand up I was like you know
because he's a spiritual guy I was like
I want to talk about how spirit is the
real thing and all that and I was like
you know stand-up doesn't work it's up
and it's down you get Whiplash from it
and he just goes
but it's also your gift and I was like
how many older men do I need to just say
like it's okay yeah it's okay but the
narcissism is going it's okay what you
brought to the potluck is okay yeah
one of the most profound so I had this
ketamine experience and and it was just
so viscerally
apparent that there's nothing you can do
to [__] it up
meaning
you can [__] this up I can call you an
[__] yeah I mean the big this yes
can't be [__] up that's right it's
Untouchable that's right and that's
right why did I just think of that I
don't know but
it's it's what I call I think I think I
said this earlier it's what I call
malevolent omnipotence yeah bad things
happen because of you and good things
happen in spite of you yeah so people
think
oh if I do this things are going to fall
apart yeah but when we do things the
right way we go I hope it goes well
right yeah so there's less the less
certainty with the good things yeah
I think maybe I said that because the
foundation underneath this is like it's
really helpful to find that Foundation
and act from it yeah and then it then it
becomes a little bit easier to go this
is my gift it's okay it's not it's not
Ultimate Reality but it's okay
that I yell she has to pee she has to
pee that's just my gift in that moment
are you you sound very very like you
sound very
healthy like you sound very powerful and
comfortable and it's really nice like
you you just like you appreciate that
you're kind of like exuding not not like
you're trying it's just who you are and
but you've always been that way but you
but you saw I mean you saw but what what
a gift thank you
you saw me at a very newborn deer and
that was and it and it really breaks my
well
I just wish that for everybody I hope
that they find mentors I hope that they
yeah and you know it's funny Mulaney
used to have a joke about
how he his first therapist he wouldn't
talk until the therapist admitted that
he wouldn't listen to him unless he was
paying him like it was like this kind of
bratty thing he I think he would say it
was bratty but I'm like but your doctor
also wouldn't yeah if you were bleeding
out it would help you in an elevator for
free before they check your wallet but
you know you go in with a big problem
they're gonna they also charge you yes
and like it just is what it is going
back to your therapist it just is what
it is
but like
there's somebody you can afford and
there's a lot of wisdom yeah I mean it
doesn't mean that I get my top fee every
time I'll see I some see people some
people pro bono also people yeah but at
least for yourself
and you know to change
is one of the things I like to say is
the difference between a lowland gorilla
and Einstein is two percent DNA I
remember that yeah so when we can we can
just access this little piece I mean
yeah it's kind of like
we could get past the atmosphere yeah
it's kind of like you see people like
you came to me
and you were like on the tarmac yeah and
there was steam coming out
and you were ready to go
right I don't think you knew it yet you
were diverted a little bit right but you
know I was pointing in the wrong
direction it's like just turn this
around real quick and but all of a
sudden as soon as you get it yeah you
start to and you start to like
grow but it's challenging and all this
Earth's gravity is trying to keep you
yeah on the tarmac but once you get past
these yeah and you're going around and
you're going around yeah and then the
world is kind of fantastic yes
that's so yeah you said I seem healthy
and that is the good news to share is
like this this work of making
unconscious things conscious
some of it was ugly and and yes very
difficult my mom and I went through a
really hard period
that she still references I still
reference it was hard for me too meaning
it was not what happens on the hero's
journey you get there's always the wound
you get wounded and you don't think
you're gonna make it yeah there's the
Dark Knight of the Soul there's you got
lost you why didn't I stay in the
village why didn't I just let what was
happening happen there was no more why
questions why are you wearing that shirt
I have bad taste yeah yeah there's only
bad answers but I could have stayed in
the Cozy at least there was a bed and
there was and it's meatloaf night that
would have been home for meatloaf that's
right so it wasn't it wasn't easy but
it's just a nice word to share that that
work
led to the partner I was supposed to
have
it led to my daughter
and and
I think people might see like oh it's
it's like I was saying it's nice to be a
success in the way that I'm a success
but the real success really is internal
I know that sounds crazy but it really
is internal like I have a partner that
if it all went away I think we I know
that we would be happy with one another
yeah that's right and she would love me
here's you're gonna this will melt your
heart I go God Lila's only four I go
this is embarrassing I go what if I'm
not doing anything cool when she's like
16. that's in 12 years what are the
chances I'll be in a TV show or movie or
something and she goes Val goes you'll
be your dad yeah and I'm like just start
crying of course you know what I mean
because you you start to get the picture
and you're you're one of those you help
me get that yeah
that's your
I you know one of the things I I tell
people I work with is what is your
Baseline
because people have all this all these
doubts like what is your Baseline of who
you are and what you do let's say as an
Entertainer as an Entertainer
Entertainer or as a thought leader
or as a friend like what is your what is
your Baseline
what I what I say to myself if someone
says to me Gary what do you think of
yourself as a therapist my Baseline is
add my worst I'm better than most yeah
that's my Baseline yeah sometimes it's
not great you know sometimes this is
it's usually in my patient's fault not
mine right that's right I'm realizing I
taped that from your playbook into my
playbook when I go home and I had a bad
sound it's not your fault Val goes how
was I go I was better than them that's
right that's so true that's better I was
better I mean the audience yeah I know I
was better than the other I know
but it's true but it is true of course
people I go off on this all the time
Seinfeld says never blame the audience I
go that's like your guitar's Out Of Tune
and you tried to play a song and the
guitar it sounded like [__] that's right
you blame the guitar yeah it was too
cold out it couldn't hold a tune yeah
why can't I blame the guitar I play the
audience that's right I'm not mad at
them no they're not idiots they're
stupid [__] them it's not that it just
didn't work didn't work bottom ten
percent uh yeah
yeah I I ripped so much from you but
that's it and that's why I'm glad we're
doing this is so people can rip it and
rip it for me and rip it from you
you're highly rippable but these these
things make
make a difference yeah it really does
they make a difference and Pete you make
a difference and I'm I'm going back to
almost when we started but
you're loved and and people people come
to see me at your recommendation main
therapist is a pretty personal thing
right and they say I will go see you
based on what Pete Holmes says right
but that's a compliment to you
I mean it's really cool and you know
I sometimes get the profound sense that
it's all like going back to the Oneness
of the universe we're all
playing with ourselves I know that
sounds like I'm trying to be funny we're
just kind of like dancing with ourselves
or something so it doesn't surprise me
that I found you and found out that
doesn't mean things always work out I'm
gonna you know we're gonna die things go
sideways I get it
but like it's beautiful and then and
then to be able to share it I just think
this is really special I hope you feel
great that you share it I feel great and
the book is called you know now it's a
late night show but it's I can't believe
my life has come to this is a collection
of your teachings yes and the new one
right now it's not out yet but they're a
little a little bit better yeah a little
bit better is it like the the ape two
percent
was that kind of the thesis is is
Einstein's only two percent better right
right right right right right right
right yeah a little well it's basically
I don't I I'm not trying to be I'm not
trying to be perfect I'm trying to be a
little better today than yesterday and a
little better tomorrow than today and I
hope that's going to be who I am until
they throw dirt on top of me yeah
I'm I believe in evolution I'm a work in
progress I think you're going to be the
same way you're going to be curious and
you're going to challenge yourself
and you're going to expand that's the
whole thing that's it right that's what
Richard Rohr says he goes why are old
people such a drag to be around it's
because their brains of atrophied
they've stopped they stopped so you
don't talk to them you they have like a
library of records that they can put on
and here's my thing and they just and
they don't want to talk about a lot of
things no like if I my mother used to
say it was one of the things if I had a
quarter for every time she says I don't
want to talk about it yeah I would be
living in ballet I mean it's just it's
they all want to like
yeah this rigid rigidity yeah it's an
Alan Watts thing and we'll close on this
but he said don't be a pond upon it
becomes all scummy and you know so true
it's one of my things is like sometimes
like people's relationships
are like a pond I use that analogy all
the time he stole it from Midnight ah no
it's nature is there and it looks
beautiful right but the water's dank
like you can't drink like you need a
brook yeah you needed to go over rocks
yeah to purify the water I'm not just
saying this I realize one final
compliment I really think not only did
you shave my psyche and help me navigate
my young adulthood which was just so
necessary and were this Father Figure
and remain a voice in my psyche that I
consult with not I don't to personalize
but I mean like you're in there but I
think you also just like you helped my
comedy and taught me how to like like
when you the nipple thing right if we
breastfed from our dads I did that on
stage I didn't know it was you but you
said it without embarrassment the guy
that I take it is a great stride forward
that I can just go like and I heard my
neighbors having sex and I jerked off
you know what I mean like that's one of
the things that's a prerequisite for
comedy but it's just a prerequisite
requisite for spaciousness and Clarity
and go like I don't know why but
that kid's face freaks me out or
whatever it is like just can we just say
it like I don't know why maybe that guy
looks like someone who bullied me but
that kid's face freaks me out like it's
oh it's okay okay yeah let and and
Define the people around you so James
Finley who's beautiful his episode came
out a couple weeks ago
he says your partner is someone who you
know we're all wearing masks and we
don't want to take them off
and the and you think you should but
you're afraid everyone will leave you if
they see you classic and he goes your
partner you meet your true partner they
don't take off your mask they straighten
it for you they go let me help you there
you go now that is that is so perfect
isn't that beautiful and then he goes
and then eventually The Mask becomes
transparent you're still wearing it but
it becomes transparent because they love
you isn't that great and that's what you
did that's what bounded but you loved me
in that way well that's what cares doing
this entire podcast
wow but that's what it is it's free to
give you've given it rare to find though
so I hope there's a little bit more
because of this conversation I'm
thrilled to see you same here p and I
love you I love you too thank you I know
would you say keep it crispy it seems so
silly but the guest says keep it crispy
it's how we sign off it's a Rite of
Passage
keep it crispy Pete you keep it
Christmas all right
all right let's go cry
[Music]